nos dicen cuál podría ser la ecuación de
p y aquí tenemos la gráfica de nuestro
polinomio p
puedes verlo como la gráfica de ye igual
a px
así que pausa el vídeo e intenta
encontrar la respuesta bien vamos a
trabajar juntos puedes ver que todas las
opciones nos dan ap de x factor izado
con esto es sencillo identificar los
ceros o los valores de x que hacen tu
polinomio igual a cero por otra parte
podemos ver la gráfica y cuáles son sus
ceros estos serán los valores donde
interese que hemos al eje x también
conocidos como intersecciones x podemos
ver que cuando x es igual a menos 4
tenemos un cero ya que nuestro polinomio
tendrá el valor de 0 aquí es decir
sabemos que p de menos 4 es igual a 0
además podemos decir que
de uno más un medio o podemos decir de
tres medios
pd tres medios es igual a cero y por
otra parte sabemos que pd3 es igual a
cero así que pensemos para qué expresión
se cumple esto dado que estas opciones
están en forma factor izada una de las
partes del producto para que el
polinomio sea cero para cada uno de
estos ceros bien veamos para que un
polinomio sea igual a cero cuando x es
igual a menos 4 probablemente queremos
tener un término como x 4 que sea factor
en él o debería decir queremos que este
producto tenga a x + 4 como factor ya
que x + 4 es igual a cero cuando x es
igual a menos 4
tenemos a x4 aquí y observa también
tenemos a x4 por acá así que me gustan
estos dos incisos b y de ahora para esta
segunda raíz tenemos que pep de tres
medios es igual a cero por lo tanto
estoy buscando algo como x menos tres
medios en nuestro producto pero observa
ninguno tiene a x menos tres medios como
hemos mencionado en otros vídeos podemos
multiplicar esto por constantes es decir
para deshacernos de esta fracción si
multiplicamos por 2 esto es lo mismo que
2 x menos 3 y puedes comprobarlo 2x
menos 3 es igual a cero cuando x es
igual a tres medios y observa justo aquí
tenemos a 2x menos 3 así que el inciso
de se ve muy bien pero verifiquemos con
el último para ps3 igual a cero debemos
tener como expresión a x menos 3 en el
producto porque esto es 0 cuando x es
igual a 3 tiene
lo tenemos aquí así que el inciso t es
el correcto cuando x es igual a menos 4
esta primera parte es igual a 0 lo que
hace que toda esta expresión sea igual a
0 cuando x es igual a tres medios 2x
menos 3 es igual a 0 lo que hace que
todo el producto sea igual a 0 y cuando
x es igual a 3 x menos 3 es igual a cero
y 0 por algo por algo será igual a cero